criticism is never easy to learn that
others judges to be foolish perverse
ugly or unpleasant is one of the most
challenging aspects of any life however
the impact of criticism is hugely
variable and depends ultimately on a
rather unexpected detail what sort of
childhood we have had the clue as to
whether criticism will be experienced as
merely unpleasant or wholly catastrophic
lies in what happened to us many decades
ago in the hands of our earliest
caregivers what is meant by a bad
childhood is here a matter rather simply
of love an infant arrives in the world
with a very limited capacity to endure
their own being it is the tolerance
enthusiasm and forgiveness of another
person that gradually acclimatize --is
us to existence our caregivers
characteristic way of looking at us
becomes the way we consider ourselves
it's by being loved by another that we
acquire the art of looking
sympathetically on our craft in
troublesome beings it's simply not in
our remit to believe in ourselves on our
own we are utterly reliant on an inner
sense of having been valued inordinately
by another person at the start as a
protection against the subsequent
neglect of the world we don't need to be
loved by many one will do and twelve
years might be enough sixteen ideally
but without it the eternal admiration of
millions would ever be able to convince
us of our goodness and with such a love
the scorn of millions will ever need to
be fatal bad childhoods have an
unfortunate tendency to drive us to seek
out situations in which there is a
theoretical possibility of receiving
outsized
which also means along the way a high
risk of encountering outsized
disapproval the emotionally deprived
return almost manically to the question
never really settled of do I deserve to
exist and this is why they typically put
unusual efforts into attempts to be
famous and visibly successful but of
course the world at large will never
give the emotionally nervous the
unqualified confirmation they seek there
will always be dissenters and critics
people too bashed about by their own
pasts to be able to be kind to others
and it's too these voices that those
with bad childhoods will be accused
however enthusiastic the crowd as a
whole might be we can observe along the
way that the chief marker of being a
good parent is that once child simply
has zero interest in being liked by
large numbers of strangers we don't all
hear the same thing when we are
criticised some of us the lucky ones
hear just the surface message from the
here and now for example that our work
fell short of expectations that we must
try harder with our assignments that our
book film or song wasn't excellent this
can be bearable but the more wounded
among us if the farm criticism takes
them straight back to the primordial
injury an attack now becomes entwined
with the attacks of the past and grows
enormous and unmanageable in its
intensity the boss or unfriendly
colleague becomes the parent who let us
down everything is pulled into question
not only was the work subpar we are a
wrench and undeserved being a piece of
excrement the worst person in the world
for that's how it will felt back then in
a fragile defenseless infant mind
knowing more about our tricky childhoods
provides us with a vital line of defense
against the effects of criticism it
means that we can be on our guard when
we are attacked against raising the
stakes unnecessarily we can learn to
separate out the verdict of today from
the emotional verdict we are carrying
around with us and always seeking to
confirm with the use of current events
we can learn that however sad the
attacks we are facing they are as
nothing next to the real tragedy and the
effective cause of our sadness that
things went wrong back then and so we
can direct our attention to where it
really belongs away from today's critics
and towards the unconvinced parent of
yesteryear we can forgive ourselves for
being in this area through no fault of
our own faithfully sensitive and in
essence mentally unwell we cannot stop
the attacks of the world but we can
through an exploration of our histories
change what they mean to us
we can also importantly get a second
chance we can go back and correct the
original verdict of the world we can
take measures to expose ourselves to the
gaze of friends all more ideally of a
talented psychotherapist who can hold up
a more benign mirror and teach us a
lesson that should have been gifted us
from the start that like every human
whatever our flaws we deserve to be here
at the school of life we believe that
confidence is a skill we can learn our
confidence prompt cards are designed to
help us master this mysterious art click
now to learn more